(happy music)
- So you're just gonna like pay someone
to come over and hang out with your cats?
- Yeah, they can't take
care of themselves.
- Well, why don't you just let 'em go
and hang out with the neighborhood cats?
They'll form like a Lion King.
- They're gentle cats Calen,
they can't survive on the outside.
Isn't that right Mr. Harris?
- How did his face get
all smushed like that?
- That's the breed, they're
supposed to look like that.
- Oh, so you didn't
like raise him in a jar
like one of those Japanese
cubed watermelons?
- No Calen, cats cannot grow in jars.
I did not do that.
- If I had a cat I'd want him
to just be a furry cube with legs.
(knocking)
- Oh that's one of the
people that answered my ad.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, what are you doing?
- I'm gonna be gone for a week,
it's already getting sour.
- Please, you go do the interview,
let me worry about the food.
- All right, you're not
gonna drink it are you?
- No.
- I see you have degrees
in cat and dog behavior.
- It's important to know the enemy.
- True, there's a war brewing
with the dog community.
What is your experience with problem cats?
Mr. Harris has two strikes
with the humane society.
- Mr. Harris, come.
- Wow.
He doesn't usually respond to English.
Impressive, Albert.
(knocking)
Excuse me for just a second.
- Hi, I'm Jenny.
- Oh, hi.
- I'm here for the cat-sitter interview.
- Oh right, Jenny.
Hi I'm Elliott, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Uh, you're here early though.
- Oh, I can come back later.
- No, no, you should stay.
- [Jenny] Okay.
- Just give me a second.
- Sure.
- One sec, just--
- [Jenny] Okay.
- I'm sorry, one second.
Hey Albert this is Calen,
he's Britney Purrs's cat godfather.
- Hey, don't call me that.
- Yeah, so why don't you guys hang out
and talk about cats for a while?
You love cats, right?
Okay, bye.
- Hey, you know that show Cat Dog?
You ever seen one of those?
I have.
- So you're an actress living in L.A.?
- Yeah, it's been okay.
I do a lot of side gigs
to keep the lights on.
- Oh yeah, I bet, like dealing drugs and--
- Oh yeah, yeah.
Heroin, meth, coke.
- Oh my god, really?
- No, no, no, I'm totally kidding.
- Oh, right (laughs).
Yeah cool, cool, super cool.
So, do you like cats?
- Mmm hmmm, yeah.
I have a cat, Banjo.
He's a little shy, but super sweet.
- Oh, that's great.
And have you ever cat-sat?
- No.
- Albert's the clear choice,
but something about Jenny.
- You can just say you like her.
- Is it unethical to hire someone
because you wanna date them?
- No, I mean I went out
with my probation officer.
- You're a terrible person.
- I'm a great person.
- You have a probation officer.
- Elliott, I'd expect you
of all people not to buy
into America's prison industrial complex.
- I just, I wanna know my
cats are gonna be okay.
I need to hire the best person.
- I mean, you can really
do whatever you want.
I kinda don't care anymore.
- Yeah, you're right.
I'm gonna move on to phase 2.
- Sure.
- Okay, it's time for
Britney Purrs's pill,
how do you give it to her?
- Insert the capsule into an
edible pill pocket, place it
in her mouth and gently
massage it down her throat.
- Just hide it in some
delicious human food.
- I love human food.
- Human food often contains spices
which are poisonous to cats.
- That is true.
Next question, Mr. Harris is
sitting in the loaf position
on the couch and will
not move, what do you do?
- Awww, well first take a
photo because that's too cute.
- Loafing can be a sign of stress.
I would have to call the vet.
- All right, next question.
Britney Purrs has mild hemorrhoids,
what happens when she can't move
due to the burning sensation?
- With me at all times.
- Are those clinical strength?
- Indeed.
- Welcome to the free-form
section of the interview process.
So, how would you describe
their fantasy island?
- It'd be a little island
with just this house in it.
- That's it?
- You'd be in it, all the time.
You'd never go to work.
Because you're their whole universe.
(laughs)
- Yeah.
Thank you for coming, Albert.
But, I'll see ya.
Good luck with your hemorrhoid
ointments and all that.
Okay, bye.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- I'll see you next Friday.
- Yes, please, I can't wait.
- [Jenny] Yeah, bye.
- Bye.
- Did you ask her out?
- No, not yet.
- And, you're not going to.
- Probably not, I'm terrified.
- Yeah.
Cat threw up on your bed.
- [Elliott] But my cats can't throw up.
Did you drink all their milk?